so
here's how to conceptualize yourself in
union terms
the part of you that you consider you
roughly speaking jung considered the ego
and you might
think about that as the most individual
part of your
psycho physiological being
i
mean
the difference between individual and
collective in that
sense is that
you share very many attributes with
other
people obviously
your physical form is very much like
that of other people and then you share
attributes with
other living creatures way back down the
phylogenetic chain
and so in that regard there's nothing
specifically individual about you
but the part of you that you identify
with most
completely and that you regard as unique
that's
the union ego
now jung sort of conceptualized your
psyche
as a
i would say as a place i suppose
that many spirits could inhabit
and you might think about a spirit
from from the union perspective as
a personality that can inhabit the
psyche
and so like all the psychoanalysts jung
regarded the psyche as a
relatively loose collection
of partially integrated personalities
and each of those personalities had
their own perspective
their own thoughts like their own way of
looking at the world that would be the
perspective their own thoughts their own
emotions their own habits their own
actions and those are roughly aggregated
into some sort of unity
and that was the
that was the ego
now
the ego has a public face
and the public face young called the
persona persona means mask and the
persona is both
that part of you that you show to other
people instead of the part that you hide
and then also to some degree it might
be the form that your ego takes even to
you
so for example if you're a naive person
you might think that your public face is
all there is of you
the the rough difference between the ego
and the persona might be conceptualized
this way that
you know there are things that you think
that you won't say in public
maybe not even in private
some of those things you're pretty aware
of and those would be thoughts that are
relevant to the ego but not the persona
and then some of them
you don't even really want to be aware
of and jung would consider those more
associated with the shadow
now
the shadow the existence of the shadow
first of all you might want to remember
that the best way to conceptualize
jung's archetypal
constructions is in some sense as
metaphors
so
you could say that well jung thought
that it was useful to separate up the
psyche into persona in ego
and then shadow
it isn't that there aren't other ways
that it could be broken up
but
breaking it up this way is useful for
certain purposes and jung regarded this
terminology as particularly useful from
a psychoanalytic perspective and also
from a historical perspective
so
perhaps the divisions could have been
made could be made otherwise and there
are many ways of looking at archetypes
but this is sufficiently useful to
progress with
now
people's personas are generally
somewhat harmless and somewhat
socialized
if you don't know how to act in public
you don't have a well-crafted persona
you know some of you are going to be the
kinds of relatively deep thinking
intellectuals
who think that small talk is nonsense
and uh
there's some utility in that thinking
because in some sense from a
philosophical sense obviously it's
nonsense but if you don't know how to
make small talk basically what that
means is that you have a poorly
developed persona
and what that'll mean is that you're not
going to do very well
at least at the beginning of social
in social engagements because you need
to be able to convince people that
you're basically civilized and social
before
it's even reasonable for them to go
beyond pleasantries with you and the
ability to exchange pleasantries in a
relatively banel way in a variety of
different circumstances is part of
having a persona
and you don't want to
denigrate the utility of that because
you need it you know as you progress in
your careers for example you're going to
be thrust into situations where you
don't really know anyone
and
the purpose of the gathering is to
familiarize
a large number of people with one
another and
there's a skill that's associated with
that that's
somewhat glib social ability
the unions would say well
you shouldn't
if you don't have a persona you're just
a disaster but by the same token you
shouldn't be only persona because one of
the possibilities is that the ego can
identify with the persona and then the
person thinks that they are what they
show the social world
and
the problem with that at least from the
union perspective is that
um
a people are a lot more than
the persona they're a lot more than the
ego
and b
a lot of the things that make them more
than mere persona or mere that more than
mere ego are not necessarily things that
are acceptable
in casual public
gatherings
so for example
because of
your psychophysiological makeup
you all have the capacity for aggression
now a lot of you especially the ones
that are more agreeable
you could say that even
it's either that that capacity for
aggression has been underdeveloped
because you've identified with a certain
mode of social being or you could say
perhaps if to the degree that
agreeableness is temperamental that the
aggressive tendency isn't as powerful in
you as it is in other people
that might lead you to make judgments
like and i'm sure some of you
perhaps some some of you who had an
angry parent or particularly an angry
father have decided at some point in
your life that to be aggressive is wrong
to be angry is wrong for example or to
be aggressive is wrong it's morally
wrong
one of the things that happens in
psychotherapy very frequently though is
that
people come into psychotherapy for a
variety of reasons some of them are
merely practical they're having problems
in adaptation because their lives have
got very very complicated and they
really don't know what to do about it
sometimes they go into psychotherapy
because they have very high levels of
negative emotion and that can be
associated with the first problem but
very often they come into therapy
because
they're getting pushed around constantly
and they really don't have anything
that's a sufficiently well-developed
personal identity
and generally
those that happens by the way most more
often with women than it does with men
and that's because women are
by
temperament more agreeable than men and
perhaps also by socialization
temperament certainly plays a big role
often then the the goal of therapy is
assertiveness training
and assertiveness training you could
think of as the behavioral psychologists
equivalent to incorporating the shadow
so
you know you may think well it's it's a
necessary part of existence to be nice
to other people
and there's some truth in that
not really it's a very shallow way of
looking at the world because nice is not
a very sophisticated word but even if
that's the word that you do use
you should also be nice to yourself
and sometimes what that means is that
you have to put forward your own wishes
and desires in a manner that causes a
certain amount of conflict and in order
to to withstand that conflict you have
to have you have to be able to draw on
the the sources of aggression that in
some sense are are are are
a deep part of your
your inbuilt set of possibilities now
the reason that's necessary in part from
a biological perspective is that
people are often afraid of engaging in
conflict
because they're afraid because because
because conflict can be real trouble
and
anger inhibits fear
so if you don't have a well-developed
capacity for well we could say rage
then you can't overcome your fear
and then you can't stand up for yourself
and then you're going to get run over
now the problem with that is is that if
you get run over enough it'll make you
resentful
and then that will make you aggressive
except it'll make you aggressive and
sneaky underground and somewhat
unconscious ways that are
much less likely to be productive than
you know a frank
exchange of viewpoints and some
conscious negotiation
so
one of the things i do in therapy for
people who need assertiveness training
is i get them to pay attention to their
resentment and resentment is often a
good
avenue into the shadow
because first of all resentment is a
pretty destructive emotion it's
extremely useful emotion but it can be
very destructive because it gives rise
to
well first of all sense of victimization
and second then the underground growth
of all sorts of ideas of revenge and
vengeance and
and also a kind of stubborn
non-cooperativeness
because who wants to cooperate when they
feel taken advantage of
and so
part of jung's idea with regards to the
shadow is that
obviously the social world wants you to
be peaceful and predictable and maybe
even easy to get along with
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
peaceful predictable and easy to get
along with a are the only virtues
because they're certainly not and one
thing we know about virtues is that if
they're taken to too great and extreme
they become vices
and b they're certainly not the only
virtues
you know there are what you might call
darker virtues
so to speak they're they're more
dangerous virtues in some sense because
they harness forces that can be very
destructive if they're not utilized
consciously and aggression is a
certainly an example of that
so
here's some fundamental rules about the
shadow that you might
think about as you move forward through
your life
so a lot of times you're going to have
to negotiate on your own behalf and so
what that means from the perspective of
agreeableness and aggression is that you
should be able to stand up for yourself
at least as well as you would stand up
for someone that you care for
so the problem with the idea of being
nice to other people is that it doesn't
take you into account and that's
supposed to be an equation even though
it's as i said nice is a pretty weak
philosophical term
but
the fundamental rule is that you should
certainly include yourself in the circle
of people who deserve
respect and care and that means that you
have to be willing to advocate for
yourself and if you're willing to
advocate to yourself for yourself and
you want to do it you have to be able to
say no
you have to because otherwise you have
to say yes and then you can't negotiate
and in order to say no
you have to have armed yourself with
strategies and plans that enable you to
say no you can't be dependent you can't
be afraid of potentially searching out
new opportunities etc you have to be
willing to stand your ground and it's
very difficult to do that without
drawing on some of the deeper sources of
psychological energy that are part of
our
psychophysiological heritage
so
young would say well there's the persona
and the ego and you can identify with
your persona and then your you're you're
kind of a shallow puppet of culture so
pinocchio as the marionette is a persona
pinocchio himself is an ego but as a
marionette
he's the persona so anybody who's
ideologically possessed by the way is a
persona although they're also possessed
by the shadow even though they don't
know it and you can tell when someone's
ideologically possessed because you can
predict whatever they're going to say
once you know a few axioms of their
particular ideology so a given ideology
probably has four or five explanatory
axioms like
everything is caused by economic
disparity that might be one
or
success is due to hard work that might
be another and those are broad enough
statements even though they're in
opposition to one another both of those
statements are broad enough so you can
virtually explain everything with them
the problem with it is is that you can
predict what the explanation is going to
be before you even have to talk to the
person and whenever you're talking to
someone and you can predict exactly what
they're going to say because they're
using some
ideologically mediated structure then
you know perfectly well that they've
identified with the persona
you also know that they're likely to be
possessed by a pretty vicious shadow
because we know that the shadow of
ideological possession is
repression and
death
so one of the things that's always
interesting about the psychoanalysts is
that whenever they see something good
they're always looking for the dark side
of it and vice versa by the way whenever
they see anything dark they're looking
for the good side of it and so they're
very unlikely to take anything at face
value and so if someone comes up to you
and says
i stand for
some good thing
the thing that you ask if you're
psychoanalytically minded is
well what does that mean that you hate
because there's a reasonable probability
that even though you think that you're
standing for something that a lot of
what's motivating you is the desire to
be against something and that's
particularly the case when you're
dealing with
with negative emotions because they're
more powerful than positive emotions
so
it's one of the things george orwell who
is one of the 20th century's great
anti-ideologues published a book in the
1940s 30s 40s called
road to wigan pier where he went to stay
with some coal miners in the north of
england and those coal miners man they
had a hard life like
some of them had to crawl three quarters
of a mile to work in tunnels in the
morning in tunnels where they couldn't
stand up just to get to work
so and then they do their like 10 hour
shift in the coal mine digging out coal
then they'd have to crawl back
three quarters of a mile underground you
know so they they had very very hard
lives and so
you know orwell was pretty
um unimpressed by the conditions in
which they were forced to work so he
wrote an essay for the
english left book club
and they were so that was a socialist
publishing house but he appended another
essay to it where he criticized the
socialists who were most likely to read
that sort of book as much more oriented
towards hating the rich than
than loving the poor
that's devastating criticism and the
left book club didn't even want to
publish his book but they ended up
publishing it's become a very famous
essay but it lays out a general
principle it's like if you have
identified with a given persona which is
like a a social machine in a sense
and you think you're all good because of
what you think then you might ask well
where'd all the parts of you that aren't
good go because
unless you think that you're a saint and
that everyone who thinks differently
than you is satan himself then you're
missing a chunk of yourself you're not
taking a chunk of yourself into account
and that's the part that is nowhere near
as well behaved or as benevolent as
you might think or that you actually
have any reason to believe
you know and so one of the things that
that has struck me as a consequence of
analyzing 20th century history and and
often through a union lens is that
there's not much evidence that the sorts
of atrocities that characterize the
soviet union
um
and and nazi germany were the result of
a few extremely corrupt people at the
top of the hierarchy forcing everyone
down into slavery and then making them
do terrible things
i think that's a very weak explanation
in fact i think it's i think it's wrong
i think the historical record is quite
clear that it's wrong i mean in east
germany for example
one third of the people were government
informers
so that means if you had a family of six
two of your family members were
reporting on you to the government
so when you look at
human capacity for destructiveness
if you don't regard yourself as one of
the agents of that destructiveness or at
least one of the potential agents of
that destructiveness
then from the union perspective at least
there's a high probability that you're
part of the problem rather than part of
the solution
now that doesn't necessarily mean that
you should be blamed for it
because
blame has to come from another person
and it isn't obviously clear that like i
get to blame you for being potentially
violent
that's i think is a complete mistake
but
if you
if you familiarize yourself with the
realm of human capability and then you
regard yourself as human what that means
is that you have to regard yourself as a
creature that's capable of what human
beings are capable of and human beings
are capable of a lot of things and some
of them are absolutely wonderful i mean
there's nothing more remarkable than a
human being on the planet i mean
people can do amazing things but the
downside of that is that we can do
absolutely horrible things and it's not
obvious that it's only the pathological
people who do that in fact it's it's
that it's not reasonable to assume that
so
the shadow for jung was a very big deal
you know and he believed in some sense
and this is where the ideas get
archetypal he believed that the ideas of
of
uh the evil
twin of the king or the evil twin of god
for that matter so that would be satan
and christian theology that was a that
was as real a representation of the
human
and transpersonal human capacity for
evil as there was and he believed that
if you look deep enough into your own
foul motivations
and if you look far enough down that
you'd be looking so to speak into hell
itself and you'd find the main
controller of hell deep inside your
psyche
so it was no
journey for the timid
and jung also believed that
and this is what separates him from a
new age thinker because he's often
accused of being a new age thinker
new age thinkers tell you things like
follow your bliss and you'll you know
you'll run into utopia you're on counter
utopia but that isn't what the unions
especially jung
said
about
his process of individuation at all he
said that
if you follow what's meaningful and you
do it honestly it will take you
somewhere you really do not want to go
and
until you go there you'll never be able
to climb up higher on the other side
and so that
provides a real impediment for
enlightenment because for enlightenment
there's a price to be paid and
if you look at archetypal
representations of the cost of
enlightenment you often find that the
person who becomes enlightened has is
damaged in some profound way before it
happens
so for example
in the ancient egyptian stories of horus
and osiris horus loses an eye when he
has to encounter seth who's the ancient
egyptian equivalent of satan
so it's no joke
it's seriously no joke you know and it's
you know one of one of young's
propositions essentially was that the
human race will continue to be
plagued by
phenomena like
the outbreak of the genocidal nazi and
soviet ideologies until people realize
that
the nazis and the soviets are them
that it isn't someone else's problem it
isn't other people who aren't you
it's you
if you were there it would have been you
and you might say well no i would have
been a hero it's like
no
probably not because they were rare and
i mean unless you have real reason to
think that you could have done it
then it's safer to think that you
couldn't have and wouldn't have
and so then there's a responsibility
that goes along with that
and the responsibility is to
broaden your capacity of who you are so
that you have the possibility of
controlling the parts of your psyche
that are very dark now let me give you
some examples of this so you know
there's a philosopher named russo and
most of you are russoians without
knowing it and rousseau basically made
the following propositions he said that
human beings were basically good
but they were corrupted by culture
so human
essential human nature was good and the
corrupting influence was
was society
now
that's true but it's only half true and
there's a philosopher named hobbs who
said exactly the opposite thing he said
no human beings are base and violent and
uncontrollable and unless we have
society structuring their interactions
he was more like freud structuring their
interactions they would be constantly at
one another's throat
and then if you think well who's right
rousseau or hobbes
first of all they're both right even
though they say the opposite thing and
second well you look around the world
and you tell me whether there are more
hobbesian states or resilient states an
answer that's pretty clear
most countries are disastrous
authoritarian dictatorships in which
people where people live and suffer and
the places where
civilization has has become stable
enough so that people can live
peaceful
relatively peaceful and productive lives
are very rare they're more common than
they were in the past and they seem to
be getting more common all the time
thank god but
it's a lot easier to be disorganized and
brutal than it is to be organized
productive and free
so
now
jung believed that
the the shadow is something that kind of
comes apart when you when you face it so
it's a blurry black mass and so
in in a sense before you start to
differentiate it and so
you can you can tell what the shadow is
as far as any one of you is concerned
because
you
you can start to notice
how you
aren't like you act
especially when you act around act
around people that you're trying to
impress or people whose opinions you
think are important to you
you have to pay attention to it though
and you you'll be able to see that
there's a distinction
between
what you say
because you're saying something in order
to make something turn out the way you
want it to turn out and what you
actually think
and the shadows at work in two ways
there one way is that it's convincing
you that using your speech and actions
to manipulate the world
in a conscious manner is a good idea and
it's not and the second is that
you'll see that there are counter
thoughts to what you think so if you for
example if you find yourself in the
position of
being too nice to someone maybe it's a
boss for example who's a bit of a tyrant
you know and you don't feel that you're
in a position to say anything
um in your own defense against
his or her bullying tactics the
consequence of that is that you'll think
all sorts of
dark and dangerous thoughts about that
person in your own fantasies
when you're not interacting with them
and if you
catch a hold of those fantasies and you
let them play themselves out
consciously you'll see that they take
you to very dark places
now
or at least to places that you regard as
very dark
so
jung's notion essentially is that when
you start to
uncover those elements of yourself that
don't fit comfortably within your
ideas about yourself is that
you discover things about yourself that
are also potentially very useful
it's as if you threw the baby out with
the bath water when you were setting up
your personality so for example earlier
i talked about people who may have
decided very early in their life that
they're just not going to get angry
it's like well
it's not necessarily something that you
want to throw away
it might instead be something that you
want to bring within the realm of your
personality so that it it can express
itself consciously
and in an articulated manner
because without anger for example you
don't have any power
which basically means that no one needs
to be afraid of you and you might think
well people shouldn't be afraid of you
and then a union might ask well what in
the world would ever lead you to believe
that
i mean
the distinction between being respected
and being feared is not clear
but i would say that you don't respect
anyone
whom you couldn't imagine fearing if
they decided to make that their priority
so
without the capacity for aggression
you're not going to get any respect
that doesn't mean that people have to
fear you but it does mean that you have
to incorporate your capacity for
aggression enough so that they would
fear you if you wanted them to
and if you think about it
that makes a lot more sense from a moral
perspective than the argument that you
should be nice to everyone because
if you're nice to everyone because you
don't have any choice because you're
weak and ineffectual and harmless
then that's not a virtue that's just you
just can't do anything else you're
you're
you're harmless by default and harmless
and virtuous are by no means the same
thing
if by contrast you're capable of causing
all sorts of terrible trouble
and you know it and you know how
and then you decide not to do it because
you can
articulate carefully articulate a
different route
well then you have the possibility of
virtue because without the capacity to
sin
so to speak there's no virtue in not
doing it
so
if you're a
if you're a young
man
who
feels that sleeping around is wrong
but never has the opportunity to do it
then you can hardly attribute that to
your virtue
so a good union would say well you're
just making a virtue out of a vice
it's just rationalization it has nothing
to do with with virtue
now if you are attractive to people
and you decide that
that
attraction should only manifest itself
within certain tight boundaries
and that's a voluntary choice
that's a whole different issue
now
when jung claims for example that you
throw the baby out with the bath water
when you're trying to develop and become
a
socially acceptable personality
that happens in a different way as far
as he's concerned for each of the
genders and so one of the prices
jung would say that we pay
and that this is a very modern idea in
some ways
for growing up
as a distinctly gendered society is that
it's very easy for men to suppress and
fail develop to develop
those elements of their character that
might be considered classically feminine
and it's difficult for women to develop
and express those aspects of their
personality that might be
classically considered masculine
and but so jung believed that nested
inside the shadow in some sense were the
contrasexual capacities so for example
for a man given what we know about the
temperamental difference between men and
women
it may be that men could be more
could develop the capacity for true
compassion
and care
if they
they could find that ability within what
they've thrown out in the shadow
and women for example could find the
capacity to be aggressive and assertive
because that's part of what they threw
out during their stage of their course
of development because of because of its
a priory categorization as inappropriate
behavior
now that doesn't mean that jung thought
that
there was that people should be raised
without any gender identity that issue
never came up for him
he just thought that once you had
established a personality that was
sufficiently
developed to be acceptable socially and
functional on the individual level
then you could have the opportunity to
expand that personality and to take into
yourself elements of of perception and
thought and behavior
that
you wouldn't have had the sophistication
to be able to handle at an earlier stage
of development
so
jung would say perhaps
that if you're a male you have to become
masculine before you could become
feminine and if you were a female the
reverse is true but that
if your development only star stops with
a narrow and categorical gender identity
then
there are elements that of of of being
that you could draw on that aren't at
your disposal and that will make you
weak
so
the shadow breaks up into the anima and
anonymous and the anima is the
female inside the male so to speak and
the animus is the male inside the female
and jung believed that he could see
those
partial spirits manifesting themselves
in people's behavior and so he talked
about a couple of typical behaviors that
he thought were associated either with
anima possession so that would be in the
case of a man or animus possession in
the case of a woman and so he would
regard
if you ever talk to someone who's female
who seems to respond to all of your
propositions with nothing but
argumentation for the sake of
argumentation you would regard that as a
manifestation of possession by the
animus
and if you ever talk to a man who
is
irrationally possessed by
rate and futile emotions
then he would regard that as possession
by the anima
so and you can see that if you watch for
it and if you believe in such things um
the best thing to do when confronted
with someone who's animus possessed is
just shut up
because you're not going to make any
headway because the point of the
argument
of an animus inspired argument is to get
you to argue
not to win
because by getting you to argue the
animus wins
so
and then behind those two things behind
the shadow and the anima and the animus
there's a final archetype which is the
archetype of the self and that's jung
believed that the self was what you were
as a totality
and that's a hard thing to understand
but
but you could think about it this way
you could think about the self as the
as the total of what you are now
plus the total of all those things that
you could still be
so it would be you as a reality plus you
as potential
and that's a strange idea right because
we don't really know how to understand
the idea of potential as modern
empirical people because potential
virtually by definition is not yet
manifest and also
not a straightforward thing to either
measure or conceptualize
by the same token
everybody acts as if they're they have
potential unrealized potential and so
jung
generated up a category to account for
that
which he felt was expressed in all sorts
of symbolic
ways so for example
the wise old man like like the wizards
in in the movies that all of you have
seen in the last five years it's always
the same wizard sometimes it's even the
same actor
it's like that's an archetype of the
wise old man
and
for young christ was an archetype of the
self as well and i i told you why that
was to some degree and it's partly
because the phoenix is also an archetype
of the self because the phoenix is
something that can die and be reborn and
so the phoenix stands for the part of
your personality that can let one thing
go one part of you which is an alive
part can let that go and burn up so to
speak so that something new can be born
because you very seldom gain something
before you let something else go
because that's partly because what you
already assume
can be
the worst impediment that you have to
toward to learning something new and
it's complicated because sometimes what
you know worked in the past
you know so you can think about that
maybe you're a perfectly well adapted 11
year old and you're still acting that
way when you're 15. it's like well
it's hard to let that go because it
worked and you put a lot of effort into
it but unless you let it go the new
personality isn't going to be able to
manifest itself so you have to stop
being a child
before you can be an adult and there's a
sacrifice that goes along with that it's
also a sacrifice that parents have to
make right because in order for a parent
to
encourage you to adopt the
responsibilities of an individual they
have to allow you as a child to die
and freud's
observation
on that phenomena was that
many parents
and he believed this was particularly
characteristic of mothers because of
their tight
bond with their children and the
dependency that that
implies that it was particularly
difficult for a mother to let her child
die so that an adult could manifest
itself in that child's place
and that's
fundamentally
in many ways the
edible complex okay so now i'm going to
show you some of these things again
because the thing about young is that
it's not easy to understand what he has
to say
and it's not a simple thing to explain
it and his books are complicated
although i don't think they're any more
complicated than they have to be like i
don't think jung is obscure
i think he's just difficult and then
beyond difficult he's actually
frightening so there's lots of reasons
that people don't like you and the fact
that he's
difficult and frightening are probably
the two foremost objections i think the
other thing that happened to jung
that maybe slowed his acceptance as an
intellectual
was that many of his students were women
like his primary students
and the people who developed his ideas
many of the people who identified
continued to develop his ideas after he
died were women and that was
perhaps not
the most effective way of making headway
in the academic world at at the time
that he was alive
so let's look at some things i'm going
to show you some things from the lion
king
because the lion king
shows you archetypes everywhere
so
let's do this first
okay so the first thing that i would
like to point out here is that
this takes place at daybreak
and daybreak is when the sun re-emerges
and from an archetypal perspective the
sun re-emerges from a terrible battle
that it had with the thing that devours
the sun at night and it comes up again
triumphant in the morning and so it's
the dawn of consciousness and that that
idea that the sun undergoes this battle
is associated with the idea that you
descend into unconsciousness when you
sleep and magically we re-emerge from it
in the morning and you do that in
accordance with the sun so for you
darkness is a time of unconsciousness
and there's a tight relationship between
unconsciousness and darkness and so jung
would say
people projected that idea it was an
idea that was it they're in their
imagination that unconsciousness and
darkness were tightly aligned
and so they use their imagination to
explain the world and conceptualize the
sun in those in those terms of
imagination so that if you analyze the
terms of imagination you can get some
understanding into the structure of the
imagination and so that's one of them
consciousness and light are the same
thing illumination enlightenment all of
those things and that's because we're
primarily visual creatures and we're
conscious during the day and so this is
a new beginning the new day which is
something that everyone also experiences
because sleep washes away the cares of
the previous day
and it does revitalize you we know
perfectly well that if you deprive
people of sleep for any length of time
it's not good for them it it dera it
derails them entirely deranges them
entirely
so
there is a reason that this movie opens
with the dawn of the day
okay so there's another re
casting of the same idea right except
the lyrics also indicated that there was
an association between
the dawn of self-consciousness and the
emergence of the light because the
lyrics were when we stepped the day we
stepped onto the planet and stepped out
blinking into the light
there's a there's a transition from
unconsciousness to consciousness
metaphor underlying that and so
one of the
statements the film is making or
one of the ways that the film is trying
to set you up to understand this as a
story about the emergence of
consciousness into the light now you
might say well did the filmmakers know
all this the answer to that is
a it depends on what you mean by no
which is really a critical factor in
this sort of discussion and
b well yes and the re the way they
manifested the fact that they knew it is
because they knew when things fit
together
so you know when you're writing a story
or something like that or reading a
story you know when the story is going
well you think yeah that makes sense in
fact you don't even notice it right you
just assume that everything's fine
because it makes sense it doesn't jar
you out of the narrative and so people
are perfectly capable especially if they
concentrated on it for long periods of
time of assembling a narrative
with images that make sense now they may
not know why it makes sense in fact if
they're actually artists they don't know
why it makes sense because they're
they're ex they're expanding their
capacity to comprehend and explain
things while they're producing what
they're producing they have to be moving
beyond what they know because otherwise
they're just producing propaganda
you know and there are elements of
many disney films that sink now and then
into propaganda sort of conscious
moralizing but when the films are really
working they're not doing that at all
and when when when they are consciously
moralizing they're boring very quickly
plus they date extremely rapidly
there's far too much
[Music]
okay so that's a brilliant piece of film
editing there because
the the filmmakers sweep your eye along
and then make something appear as a
revelation and they do it at exactly the
same time that the music swells to a
climax and that's indicating to you that
something of tremendous importance is
about to be revealed and so you see two
things here the first thing you see is
what's called pride rock which
is a is a roughly pyramidal shape at
least a triangular shape that emerges in
the middle of the landscape that
actually serves symbolically as the
center of the kingdom now you can think
about that as an egyptian pyramid or you
could think about it as a dominance
hierarchy it doesn't really matter it's
both of those things it's also the thing
on which the thing that the animals are
subjugated to stands
right because that's where the king is
and the king happens to be a lion and
the lion is a solar beast it's always
been a solar beast it's associated with
the sun and it's the king of beasts
because it's an apex predator it's at
the top of the hierarchy and for
whatever reason although obviously the
lions in the animated movie
are they're not actually lions it's
important to remember that while you're
analyzing the film because it's very
easy to just think of them as lines even
though clearly they're not
now you also see this little character
up in the right hand corner left hand
corner and that's zazu right
and zazu is the eye of the king and so
the king is on top of the pyramid
but the king's eye is free from the king
and the kid go we're all over the place
even where the pyramid can't see and
that's the eye on the top of the pyramid
you've seen that symbol everywhere no
doubt it's the symbol that's on the back
of the american dollar bill and there's
a reason for it it's because the eye of
the king is not part of the hierarchy
the eye of the king is something that's
always free of the hierarchy and can can
fly over all hierarchies
and that's
that's equivalent to the thing that
could make its way up any hierarchy in
some sense it's also the same as horus
the
the god of vision in the ancient
egyptian stories
okay so there we've got the king and
we'll see that he's on top of the rock
which is where the king belongs he's
also in full sunlight
even though that's not characteristic of
any of the other animals he's got his
little bird there that tells him things
because the king is someone who pays
attention
because the king who doesn't pay
attention is a tyrant
and then
the wind is blowing through the king's
hair because the wind is spirit
and so the king is also something that's
associated with the everlasting spirit
pneuma pneuma is the breath of air and
it's also the
the essence of life from an archetypal
perspective
so to be inspired is like ris respiring
to be inspired as to take in spirit and
the kind of spirit that the king takes
in is associated with the image of the
wind
now you've got to look at his face you
remember before i was saying because the
animators do a very good job of this
they gave him a very mature face and a
mature face is something
out of which something is coming instead
of something into which something is
coming and you'll see that
the king mufasa is always looking like
this he's very intent and focused and
and um
intimidating whereas his son right up
until he becomes
um
initiated
is
like this
always as soon as he becomes initiated
and i'll show you that in the film his
face hardens and it isn't until his face
hardens that he can go back and fight
scar who's basically a figure of the
shadow
now originally this character
rafiki
was going to be one of those typical
sort of disney sidekick buffoons
that didn't work out so well in the
narrative and he ended up as a symbol of
the self instead
and rafiki is obviously a shaman and
he's the part of the psyche that guides
its transformation so here's another way
of looking at the self
it's very interesting idea so
you know
as you go through life there's going to
be triumphs and then catastrophes and
when there's a catastrophe the psyche
falls apart
and then maybe it gathers its resources
back together and pulls itself together
it's going like this
well jung would say the self
is what's guiding that process so the
ego feels it like this so that's triumph
and catastrophe and triumph and
catastrophe or tragedy and comedy but
the self is the thing that's underneath
all of it
allowing those transformations to take
place and that's rafiki and that's why
he's associated as well with the sun
so and he's a good king because he's in
touch with the self
so
that makes him
not something that's either serving his
persona or his ego
but you could say that what he's serving
is a manner of ruling that allows for
the appropriate amount
of
stability and transformation to take
place in the kingdom so that it remains
stable but also adapting to change and
the king is guided in that by the little
bird who tells him what's going on in
those places he can't see
now that's clearly a madonna and child
image
and the reason for that is quite simple
i mean you might think well why would
the idea of the madonna and child which
by the way is a far older idea than the
christian representation of it there's
lots of figures of madonnas and madonna
adonis and children yeah
in ancient egyptian art for example now
be isis with horus well the reason that
that's an archetype is because any
society who doesn't regard the dyad of
mother and infant as something sacred
which would mean of highest value is
doomed
obviously because without that being
held as a value the society will cease
to propagate and that will be the end of
it so if the society isn't structured so
that that's
that
that dyad is
up among the highest of values then the
society has become
ungovernably corrupt
so you see rafiki there just anointed
the little king with
something that was orange and that was
something like the sun so the idea that
the film is expressing is that there's
some sun-like substance that's being
associated with the
with this newborn
son of the king and that that's
uh a dramatic
manifestation of his destiny
and an indication that he has to also be
in cultured because what rafiki is doing
is a cultural act before he's going to
be complete
now the sand is also an indication that
he's mortal
now watch what happens here because the
filmmakers i think they just nail this
part so they're going to do the sweeping
thing again
and the music rises to the ultimate
climax of the song
and what's happening here is that the
self is presenting this the sun and so
it's a it's a presentation of the savior
fundamentally and that's the thing that
has just been born that's the hero
and
when the hero is presented and the sun
breaks open wide and shines on them you
would call that a synchronous event and
what happens is there's an emotion
associated with that which you will feel
and it's at that time that all the
animals bow down and they do that
spontaneously and the idea is that
there's a hierarchy here
and the little boy
in the sun is the highest element of the
hierarchy and when that manifests itself
and you can see beyond the facade facade
to something that's divine behind it the
consequence of that will be a
spontaneous bursting forth of awe
and i really think the filmmakers nail
that here
[Music]
me
yeah so they hit that pretty hard there
so there's also a nuclear family thing
going on in the background that you
might have noticed because of course
the little king has
a mother and a father and that's partly
because
that works better but also partly
because the
the archetypal hero is the son of
culture and nature
so okay so here's a here's a shadow
figure
here he he's represented here not so
much as simba's shadow
although he's part of simba's shadow
he's represented as mufasa's shadow and
so it's quite a complex idea because
what it says is
when when a king-like organization grows
up which means any organization anything
that's a hierarchy and that's powerful
there's a shadow element to it that
tends towards totalitarianism and
tyranny
and that's represented often by the
king's evil brother it's a very common
motif in
in
mythologically based stories and the
king is generally blind to his brother
so
often willfully blind although that
doesn't really seem to be the case in
the lion king it's it is clearly the
case that
mufasa underestimates the danger posed
by his usually older and smarter brother
it's and and the myths very often make
the case that the evil king is the older
one and also the one that's more
intelligent and the reason for that is
that
as far as i can tell is that
intelligence is something that can go
very wrong if it goes wrong and one of
its big temptations is that it produces
models of the world and then falls in
love with the models and when it falls
in love with the models that makes it
totalitarian because it believes that
its constructions are good enough so
that there doesn't need to be anything
else so it eliminates the necessity of
the transcendent and that's definitely a
characteristic of any totalitarian
system it says this is everything we
need and then you know if you happen to
suffer or if you happen to
openly rebel against the system then
you're regarded as
an enemy of truth and then it's fine to
do with you whatever might be done
because everything worth doing has
already been done
now
he's got an interesting
facial expression and it's really worth
watching facial expressions in
animated cartoons because they're not
faces right what they are is the
consequence of the observations of
extremely talented artists about how
people's faces configure themselves over
very long periods of time because these
people are high level artists they know
what they're doing and so they're able
to distill down certain facial
expressions to describe a character now
this guy's obviously he's whiny he's got
this super silliest and arrogant voice
so he's he's he's arrogant beyond belief
and he is also hard done by and
resentful and that's a really good and
maybe he has a reason he's got a scar
something happened to him that wasn't
good but he's taken on this attitude as
resentful victim who really deserves to
rule if only everyone could see how
wonderful he was and then he has all
sorts of reasons why the fact that he
isn't powerful has nothing to do with
his own
shall shortcomings be king
and you
shall never see the light in another day
didn't your mother ever tell you not to
play with your
what do you want i'm here to announce
that king mufasa's on his way
so you'd better have a good excuse for
missing the ceremony this morning
you'll lose more than that when the king
gets through with you he's as mad as a
hippo with a hernia
why quiver with fear
now scar don't look at me that way
well as we can tell
the eyes of the king and scar are not
friends
and that's because scar doesn't really
want to see what's going on now here's
an interesting
little archetype
okay so that's quite interesting there's
a variety of statements there that are
very
very cool so one of them is
the the kingdom is a bounded place
and so
that's playing off the idea of explored
territory versus unexplored territory or
the known versus the unknown and the
proposition there is that whatever the
dominance hierarchy happens to be
it has a limited domain of
a limited domain of competence
and the domain of competence is defined
by everything that the light touches
now this is actually something that you
can notice in your own life it's it's
quite interesting
you'll see that if you move into a new
place or a new neighborhood or if you do
anything new at all
that
nothing that you haven't attended to is
actually yours
it will it will stay
foreign in a sense and unfamiliar to you
until you interact with it with a
substantial amount of attention and
that's partly because while you're
attending to it which is an act of
conscious will
you're
you're modifying your perceptions and
your thoughts and your actions and your
emotions
to take it into account as a phenomena
and that means that you're competent
there
and it takes conscious effort to be
competent because you have to practice
being competent at a new domain and
until you've practiced being competent
in a new domain it's not yours and so
this
clip is showing what's basically an
eternal truth
which is that your territory is whatever
you've mastered and it's demarcated by
everything you haven't mastered and in
this particular representation that's
associated with
with death
it's also associated in some bizarre
sense with paradise because of course
simba encounters the elephant's grave
out in no man's land so to speak but
when he runs away across the desert he
also finds paradise and so there's a
paradoxical idea there that
the unknown contains death and
everything you need to make your life
worthwhile
here comes the anima
that's
okay so you see
that cocky
he's a cocky little rat here
okay so
he's very confident but that's
egotism and also persona well it's no
wonder he's confident he's the son of
the king you know and the fact is that
he has a position of dominance that he
doesn't deserve merely because he was
born into it and that's made him shallow
and arrogant and
possessed by a persona now this little
figure who
is basically an anima figure
always knocks him down a peg continually
knocks him down a peg how many of you
have seen groundhog day
yeah yeah you remember in groundhog day
bill murray's character is a real he's a
jackass at the beginning he's very
arrogant and he's very unskilled
and then he gets stuck in the same day
which is pretty funny because that is
what happens to you if you're arrogant
and unskilled you end up in the same
damn day that's not fun
and then
in that day he becomes attracted to this
woman who's an anima figure and for for
years as far as the film's concerned
every time he approaches her in his
arrogant and clumsy way she slaps him so
there's one scene in the movie where i
think it lasts for about 30 seconds and
it's nothing but clips of her slapping
him
probably 30 times at that point you've
seen him go through the same day in the
continually painful way that he does and
she slaps him in those longer clips and
after a while the filmmaker gets tired
of that just shows you nothing but the
slaps
you know eventually
he's brought so far down as a
consequence of being stuck in the same
day and continually being slapped that
he falls completely apart right then he
tries to kill himself one of the very
comical things about that movie is that
that doesn't work either he just wakes
up at the same day again and you know
what that means in some sense is that if
you're too damn stubborn to change you
will keep running into the same thing
over and over continually and that's why
you're in the same day because you won't
let go of it
and that might drive you even to
question the value of your own being but
that's also not a very useful adaptive
strategy you know and it is until he
starts to take his rejection seriously
that he starts to actually build some
real character right and then he starts
paying attention to the day and finds
out that there's all sorts of things
that he can do during that day to make
it rich and meaningful and as soon as he
does that enough and becomes an expert
at it poof he gets out of the
the day the same horrible day and so
that horrible day is also a
representation of
the tyranny of the state because the
state is something that's static so
anyways
nella she's
hey
yeah and while they're not paying
attention they end up in the shadows
outside the kingdom
so
here's
here's an image of
scar transforming himself essentially
first into hitler but because there's a
lot of nazi imagery in this in this
particular
clip but also into a satanic figure at
the end you'll see he's associated with
the crescent moon so he turns into the
horned demon of the night essentially
now you can see that's all images of
hell obviously
see one of the things that happened to
people like stalin for example is
stellan had nothing but contempt for
people and he thought all they ever did
was lie well
what happened to stalin is that he's he
became surrounded by people
with to whom he could demonstrate
contempt and who never did anything to
him except lie
because the reason for that was they
were so terrified of them that they
would never tell them the truth about
anything and so he got into this spiral
which is kind of the spiral of the of a
paranoid psychopath where i distrust you
so badly and set things up so that
you'll be punished so hard if you ever
deviate from the appropriate line that
you'll do nothing but lie to me and so
then i'm fully justified in my contempt
it's sort of it's like peter pan in some
sense king of the lost boys it's like
well who do you want to be king of well
the root that scar took which is
the negative archetype the shadow root
means that he's king but you know he's
king of hell and all he's got are these
brainless minions and so
you know he's king of people he wouldn't
want to associate with
it's not exactly a
it's not exactly an attainment
you you you may remember or you may not
remember that or may not know that
hitler of course set up the work the
biggest
meeting arena that the world had ever
seen for the nuremberg nazi party
rallies and there's there's something to
see they were filmed quite brilliantly
in a film called will to power
i think that's what it's called leaning
riff and stall
and
what hitler has a raid in front of him
are blocks of thousands of soldiers
everywhere as far as you can see an
absolutely perfect
uniformity
and that's the idea because if you're
already right nothing has to be
different everything can be the same as
the perfect thing the problem with that
is you're not right and things have to
change and hitler he was a master of the
use of fire as well and also put his
displays on at night and so
he took all the luftwaffes air
craft spotting
uh spotlights which were huge massive
lights maybe they must have been 20 feet
across and he had them all lined up
behind him on the stage and they would
shine
miles up into the sky and so he would
address these thousands and thousands of
people in this nighttime ritual with a
curtain of light behind him that was
several miles high it was an
unbelievably powerful pageant and the
people who made this film are drawing on
on that
to produce these images
is
saluted
[Music]
you know and modern people will say
things like well
the idea of hell is just a superstition
but then you watch this and it makes
sense
and then you think well hell is where
satan himself rules and nothing happens
but the bodies burn in death and that's
exactly what happened during the
holocaust and so thinking that these
sorts of archetypal ideas are
superstitious is it's extraordinarily
foolish and naive because they represent
possibilities of being that continually
manifest themselves and everyone knows
about them
so
you know the the
the implicit idea here is that if you
take the path that scar took which is
one of resentment and deceit as well as
arrogance which are three major motive
major major
shadow motivators then you'll end up at
best ruling over hell and it's no joke
like it's not a superstition the stories
are trying to tell you something that
that his mode of being is the pathway to
perdition and that and that the things
that happen there are so terrible and so
deep that the only way you can really
express them is
using the kind of imagery that we've
come to associate with religious and
religious imagery in a sense is imagery
that cannot be made more powerful that's
what makes it archetypal it's like a
limit you can't go past it in terms of
the representation and so when you
represent the ultimate
destiny of evil as eternal hell where
all the bodies burn forever and there's
nothing there except demonic chatter
that's about as far as you can go in
terms of your capacity to represent
something
but it's representing something
so and you can say well it's an eternal
place well that's because
this possibility is always there it
never goes away
it's always there and that's also what
makes it archetypal
and you know that because otherwise you
wouldn't be able to understand the story
and everyone knows it otherwise this
story wouldn't be i still believe it's
one of the top 10
grossing films of all time
so
obviously it makes sense
okay well i'd like to show you a lot
more but
but i can't
[Applause]
so we'll see you thursday i'm going to
post some sample questions on the
website
very soon tonight possibly tomorrow
morning possibly somewhere around there
so check it out and you'll get some
sense of what the exams will be like